thank you we've reached the halfway
point
where do you see the party 20th
century-fox sent over the sea burton
cisco pinatas it's gonna be so much fun
little bats on your way out ladies and
gentlemen please welcome chevy chase an
Academy Award nominee tonight mr. dan
Aykroyd
movies are seeing and feeling visual and
visceral let me just interrupt this
wasn't expected but has one of your old
friends a guy has started within the
business being nominated as just as
honorable as being a winner
congratulations really thank you factor
back you did a great guy
movies can plunge us into terrifying
disasters or worlds of wonder Marlon
Brando's one what like on the waterfront
and uh God confident 97th least you show
up as well well I couldn't find so Sheen
little feather so uh when a film
successfully attacks our senses at Marty
Landau I mean he's what 70s ooh North by
Northwest uh hug her I know he's fine
smart plug it was art he was good too I
go to bring him so you voted for him no
no I voted for you huh congratulation it
can transport you to anywhere in the
universe yeah yellow was probably bit of
a whole New Yorker yeah he was a little
better than you but he was oh sorry I
didn't win hi and I know Dan I love
Washington was the sentimental favorite
and uh congratulations to him but still
in my book you're the winner go ahead
thank you ah twenty century in the past
or in the future I'll we just better I
was pretty good in Christmas vacation
quite frankly I didn't get anything so
you know you can't win them all maybe
next let's do this only yes please
the nominees for best achievement in
visual effects are
in the abyss computer software was first
used to model and animate a wireframe
design next shading and texture effects
were added and the end result was the
Suliban a creature made entirely of
seawater one of the many ingenious
effects from nominees John Bruno Dennis
Muren
white Yeatman and Dennis Scott back
via this
and for The Adventures of Baron
Munchausen Richard Conway and Kent
Houston used the magic of the
blue-screen process with the help of
gyroscopic devices they succeeded in
taking the Baron and movie audiences on
an unforgettable journey into the
creative vision of director Terry
Gilliam that unloosed I'll take a look
at this scene from Back to the Future 2
and you tell it's Michael J Fox playing
three separate roles at the same time
nominees Ken Ralston Michael n Terry
John Bell and Steve gali used a
specially built camera and dolly to
photograph each member of the Marty
McFly family but then took over two
months to seamlessly composite all the
elements for this 15 second scene
Back to the Future 2
and Chevy if you will please the Oscar
goes to John Bruno Dennis Muren Hoyt
Yeatman and Dennis Kodak for the other
huh no we don't like to thank director
James Cameron for his vision inspiration
producer Gale Anne Hurd for her support
20 Century Fox and the following of best
crew members Laura buff Pete Romano rich
moolah Walt Conti gene Warren Steve
Johnson and Pat McClung I would also
like to thank James Cameron 20th Century
Fox and all the people at dream quest
images that work very very hard to make
the award come true for me
thank you I'd like to thank Bob Skotak
and my wife Dorothy Fontana without your
help I wouldn't be here thank you and
I'm here for industrial like magic and
thanks everybody who worked in the show
from up there John Knoll and every word
in the computer graphics department and
thanks so much especially to Jim Cameron
my wife Zahra and Gregory thank you
you